il y avait pas de rosbif vous savez ce
que j'ai commandé
je vais me faire un anglais
je l'ai commandé bleu
j'adore me faire un anglais l'échelle
bon je voulais remettre ce portrait à
Keen'V mais ça pas plus faire donc je
peux pas le vendre je peux pas le donner
parce que je peux avoir des problèmes
donc voilà on va pas se mentir un Keen'V
il est pas très accessible pas très
sympa et ses musiques elles sont pas ouf
pardon pas très j'ai pas
comment vous allez dire avant non je
disais que c'est c'était super ce que tu
vois les musiques qu'elles étaient
géniales ça fait plaisir et bah voilà
c'est pour ça que je t'ai dessiné je
voulais te le remettre c'est très gentil
[Musique]
c'est nerveux si tu es énervé tu bois
pas de café si tu vois pas de café tu es
pas brésilien si tu es pas président tu
danses pas et sans bas et ben tu as
froid aux jambes et si tu as froid c'est
l'hiver et l'hiver si tu as froid tu
mets un bonnet et si tu m'as abonné tu
mets pas de TOC tic toc
mon client
j'aurais mis une pièce de 2 euros et
voilà allez à bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]